[Musique]
alors que chine ue j'ai fais vraiment
coiffeur coupés très courts et à
deuxième chine-ue j'ai commencé à avoir
des trous et là ça c'était vraiment un
ménage je trouvais ça très disgracieux
donc j'ai un ami qui est venu avec sa
tous deux îles il a 14 ou
du conseil team quand j'ai accepté
je libère tout ça change pas beaucoup eh
ben ça change pas trop en génomique mon
chapeau que quand je vais en soupe à
caraquet parce que jeune artiste est le
lieu où les gens vendent
les gens qui sont en situation externe
qui en fait
vous pouvez passer vos sculptures dont
peut-être le temps ce serait à moi comme
ça donc là effectivement j'ai mes
chapeaux
quoi ça c'est un avantage est d'avoir la
tête nue on peut même tout ennui syntec
a largué en vigueur à namur aussi ses
racines
présent d'alice de ceux de plonger avec
la tête nue de l'amitié a tenu donc je
pense pas que ça enlève le labo tf1
des galets par la
guerre